for the 27th year walker furniture's
home for the holidays program
is helping those in need here in clark
county we have linda ultrowicz mitzrahi
joining us live linda you and your
fabulous team getting ready to change
people's lives for the better and we
certainly want to help get that word out
you want people to get their nominating
letters in the sooner the better correct
yes yes we're starting now now send the
letters in now
and the type of letters you want are
from friends community members
religious members of individuals who see
people in need can you elaborate
yes yeah neighbors anybody that you know
has
got a true true need and we invite the
community to write letters in
and tell us what's going on and uh
yeah we get over a thousand letters per
year
and you have to narrow that down to
about 35
families and linda as a member of your
committee and people here at channel 8
we're blown away
every year going through those letters
by the number of families and kids who
don't even have a mattress to sleep on
it's really heartbreaking
yeah it is uh helping hands of vegas
valley really helps us with
the thousands of thousand letters and
they narrow it down to about
one to two hundred they read every
single letter and then with those one to
two hundred letters they make home
visits
to verify the needs and from there they
get to
45 and then our executive committee as
you know brings it to 35.
and linda i would imagine with the
pandemic this year the need is even
greater than before
it is and uh we hope to to send hope to
our community that there's people
our community cares yeah it really does
you've got so many wonderful partners
too
star nursery they help deliver the
christmas tree and gift cards to these
families
really makes the holiday complete who
else is helping out this year
oh well they get helping hands is
really helping quite a bit and people
from the community all come together
to help make this what it is we we can't
do it alone
so it's really a community effort we're
really appreciative
but we need to get we need to get those
letters in by december 9th
and you can go to our website and submit
a letter
www.walkerfurniturehomefortheholidays.com
that's the easiest way to do it but you
can also mail a letter to either of our
two locations one las vegas and one in
henderson or drop it by either store
however you do get it to us thank you so
much linda we'll get the word out there
so people know to get those letters in
and we could get these families with
complete houses full of furniture and
christmas trees and gifts for the kids
thank you linda very very much
we'll be checking up with you in the
months to come thank you